on a un arsenal juridique commençons par
a comment dirais-je utilisent cet
arsenal juridique contre le salafiste
contre les frères musulmans le qs le
communautarisme il faut je crois ne
tolérer aucune manifestation du
communautarisme
ni les heures différencier ni le reste
la burqa nous avons réglé son compte
mais je pense que on a affaire à un
islam politique qui est en train
d'essayer de conquérir des territoires d
esprit des coeurs et il faut être
absolument intraitable sur l'ensemble de
ces manifestations
c'est la raison pour laquelle je pense
que il faut prendre des mesures j'en ai
citer quelques unes mais faute d'abord
être intransigeant est ferme sur nos
valeurs et encore une fois les faire
appliquer pourquoi est-ce qu'on tolère
des centaines de quartiers de banlieue
où les forces de l'ordre les pompiers
n'ose même plus entrer je pense qu'on a
affaire au troisième totalitarisme le
totalitarisme islamiste
il faut le dénoncer et à voir donc avec
l'islam il ce que je dis c'est que ce
que je dis très précisément c'est que
ceux qui en sont se réclament de l'islam
donc et à l'islam parce que je sais
parfaitement ayant des amis qui sont
musulmans je sais parfaitement qu'il
peut y avoir un islam compatible avec
les valeurs de la république
mais quand l'institut montaigne
l'institut montaigne franchement fait
une étude est que selon cette étude 28 %
des musulmans considèrent que la charia
est supérieure aux lois de la république
alors on s'inquiète et je pense que
c'est d'abord aux musulmans de france à
faire ce travail de contextualisation de
l'islam et ce travail de tolérance en
réalité religieuse qui est aussi un
travail qui concerne la laïcité
républicaine